c'est d'écrire depuis cinq ans il a
réussi à vaincre une longue maladie
comme on dit avec pudeur
demain je recommence chante maintenant
guy béart rencontrées par nicole perdu
langlois et gilbert usant c'est en
chanson et en cuisine que ans expert le
plus profondément et que l'on touche
tout le monde grands petits moyens vieux
jeune savant un culte soit vous allez
voir vos questions le nouveau béart est
arrivé geary aguerris plus incisif plus
optimistes toujours lucide c'est un
combat pour le réenchantement rebonjour
les copains à moi les lendemains de
chansons nouvelles
je me suis détendu pendant deux ans à
suite de diverses histoires et
maintenant des années après je le
ressors avec un risque nouveau donc
pendant au moins trois quatre mois
j'espère qu'il y aura pas beaucoup des
tentes
voilà alors balle et ailleurs mais
demain je recommence mais demain
vous pouvez retrouver ma chance c'est
certain j'ai gardé comme une flamme qui
éclaire un peu mon âme j'ai craqué une
allumette dans ma tête
dieu ma chance
il ya deux sentiments forts leur gré la
nostalgie des temps passés et
l'espérance je crois que si on sur le
plus c'est l'espérance danse l'espérance
pas folle mais les vrais espérances et
ce qui m'a fait plaisir c'est que j'ai
réussi à me amar et à rire de la france
il ya même une chanson qui parle de la
violence au jéhovah mon dieu confond les
religions bureaucratie de la croyance
qui ensanglantent nos régions de leur
vengeance au jéhovah on n'a pas du tout
utilisé bien que les aime beaucoup les
ordinateurs les synthétiseurs
on l'a jouée en direct avec des guitares
une basse bien que les instruments je
les ai tous afin de faire un disque vrai
et qui touche au coeur voilà je ne vous
entend plus les gars dans ma tête il a
dû déjà vous ne me reconnaissais plus eh
bien je regarde toutes les photos du
passé d'abord parce qu'on fait lille
joue maintenant avec ça et surtout pour
tourner la page
pour commencer en quelque sorte une
nouvelle avait une bonne nouvelle année
vierge
m
émargeant